a customer freaks out after she sees a
dog in the restaurant where she is
eating dinner it's disgusting to have a
animal inside of a public restaurant but
that's not any dog you can see the great
dane is wearing a vest that reads ptsd
service dog the great danes master is a
military veteran he's alive because he
fought for our country
to congratulations you're doing too much
i understand though
you're doing too much
i like actually he fought for a country
he suffered my husband's dad's uncle far
far people always do that they always
like mention some veteran that they
[ __ ] know
as a counter argument it's like we get
it everybody knows somebody who served
like
but we don't my dad's husband's
brother's imaginary friend served in an
imaginary war [ __ ] you my opinion still
matters breathe [ __ ]
it doesn't matter what you're doing
you're doing it my sister's aunt is half
native american i suffered racism
you're doing the most they do that doing
the most
they go to imright.com and they'll be
trying to finish off the convo
so if you guys understand ptsd service
dogs are there because
for folks suffering from ptsd the dog is
able to sense the symptoms whether it be
the erratic behavior the heart racing
whatever symptoms they might have so the
dog is able to warn them and ward warn
other people around that their
owner
is
having a breakdown so that's why people
have the service dogs it helps a lot of
people and it's something that's
becoming more and more popular generally
service dogs some that help blind people
some that help veterans are generally
accepted in a lot of indoor areas
because they serve a specific function
and they're also trained differently
okay they're trained very different
that's why you'll see them on buses and
stuff like that so
that's the context this woman saw the
dog the dog got a little bit close and
she lost it
not everybody
has the same relationship
with animals than others so although i
understand that this is a ptsd dog i
understand that i get that i don't have
the same relationship with animals than
people i know
that sleep with a dog
that kiss them on the faces and [ __ ]
to me
that's some disgusting [ __ ]
understanding is your pal
some of them calling me my son but i get
that
to me
that's a dog
that's an animal
that [ __ ] ain't coming near my face
that [ __ ]
ain't sleeping in my bed
sleeping in my bed sleeping in my bed
no
that's a dog
the restaurant i can't understand but
it's not the same thing
no it's not the same thing a service dog
a senior dog
it's not a canine it's not the same dog
i also feel that way and if i saw a dog
you know what i think in my head
is it in the kitchen
yeah
is it in the kitchen is it in my plate
is it in my my feet that dog has no
there's no chance that that dog's gonna
be in my
my plate that dog is train trained so
you're doing too the customer walks out
but returns and the argument continues
it's my opinion and it's not going to
change your opinion you ain't going to
change it you you you you none of your
country i think it's wrong i'm not going
to lie to you see that guy standing
behind her kind of just lowering his
head if that's me i'm leaving the girl
no he's not leaving
i know i'm leaving the girl
oh yeah oh i'm leaving the girl oh yeah
if only you yeah yeah i'm leaving the
girl
i'm leaving the girl yeah wait which why
are you acting a fool you can even feel
some type of way why are you out here
having a shouting mouth embarrassing on
camera
ludicrous right now what you gonna do
active fool you wanna fight you wanna
put in a complaint put in a complaint
put it come on you're screaming at
people dreaming about old folks leave
get out
get mad yell in the car literally yeah
looking stupid in public literally get
out you have no self-control
what's wrong with you if you're doing
that yeah no no if you're doing it it's
gone that public is done
i don't need to be to have all that like
who raised you no
guys
let me talk to you for two seconds do
you have bad credit i know i said that
loud don't even worry i've been in that
position you know i was young i was 18 i
got myself a credit card made bunch of
purchases that i couldn't pay blah blah
blah long story short i wish i had
something to help me build my credit
back up now i'm good and you can be good
too the extra card is not a credit card
it's a debit card you sign up to extra
you get yourself that debit card you
link it with your account and you make
purchases extra is going to link those
purchases to your credit bureau and
voila and on top of that you can get
redeemable points you're spending you're
getting points and you're helping
yourself build your credit back up
wonderful isn't it sign up today for
extra to build your credit back up link
is below or up or side i don't know
where he's gonna put it but go on the
link get your extra now
my first reaction was
making sure nobody got hurt i spoke to
the vet in the video retired master
sergeant bill austin who served in iraq
and afghanistan he was at the delaware
seafood restaurant with his wife janet
and friends and his service dog jp were
you shocked by her reaction yes yeah
we've never been screamed at like that
we've never been screamed at like that i
mean
we're white
we're the one that do the screaming
usually i've been called a kind because
you know i act a fool but this this is a
new one i'm just
here i mean we'd have we've had people
ask us questions or you know comments
about the dog because he's so big but
we've never had anybody get in our face
and just scream at us the angry customer
identified as ciara miller told a local
newspaper the video does not tell the
whole story she says she got upset
because the dog's backside got way too
close to her she also says she was
subjected to real slurs
again it's like the guy the parking dude
remember the parking dude the dude that
got caught up with the parking
if if if there's no slur
that's the first thing i'm not i'm not
talking about the dog i'm not talking
about the food if the food nasty i'll
leave a comment no tip i'll leave the
[ __ ] out if the dog is there i'd leave a
comment i'll get the [ __ ] out if it's
slur that's the first thing i'm talking
about not after an interview but you
know what this is like this is like
having a movie with scarlett johansson
dwayne the rock johnson and [ __ ] and
seth rogen
and in the trailer i just omit the fact
that dwayne the rock johnson's in the
[ __ ] movie
[ __ ] racial square dwayne drock johnson
is in your movie you lead with that
i'm not leading with seth rogen no all
right i'm not leaving with seth
macfarlane no i'm not leading with any
good name since no i'm leading with the
rock yes if you get called a racial slur
you won't be like your dog is nasty he
call i i love i love i love the rock
okay he he my dude but he is the regular
of movies like if you
he's a leading role if you call me a
racial slur that's a leading role in
this conversation the rock is
okay that's what he is okay i'm talking
about the rock all right so you lying
and let's be honest i want to watch the
full clip just so we don't have to waste
a bunch of time because it's just her
screaming at no point in that three
minute video did she ever say anything
about racial slurs so she had a full-on
shouting match yelled about everything
under the sun and never mentioned it but
afterwards come to the news time all of
a sudden you start pulling out racial
slurs boo-boo come on now
okay no
what what you trying to smoothie us no
you trying to juiciest the cat yeah
because black folks at home we're not
stupid we're not all right
i may have been born at night but i was
not born last night okay
preach you already know you are you
already we're not stupid you know okay
guys you know i'm gonna get behind you
hate crime all that stuff i got you girl
we support you but if you're faking it
you need to take a long-ass walk because
you're making us look stupid that karen
is you right now yes and you're you're
the carriage yeah
yes you just move you you you had a bad
you had a bad day i can understand that
it's okay
but you're doing the most you're doing
you're doing the most you're doing too
much right now and all the black folks
are watching rhino let me know if you
believe her thing you know i'm gonna
link the original video where you can
watch the whole thing and let me know if
you really believe that something
inappropriate was said i want to hear
from you guys anything else you want to
say
you're doing the most you're doing the
most